ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะผู้หญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนไปแล้วนะคะก็วีดีโอนี้ก็
กลับมาเจอกับครูหญิงบ่ก็ก็ครูฟ้านะคะอีก
แล้วค่ะในกินเอ้อ Class หนาค่ะใส่ค่ะน้า
หนูฟ้าขานี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันเสาร์ค่ะ
วันนี้วันเสาร์
วันเสาร์ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันเสาร์ที่ 26
กว่าเดือนอะไรคะเดือนกุมภาพันธ์
ปีพศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
4 คศอะไรคะเมื่อปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อ
วานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวันนี้วันศุกร์
วันศุกร์ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันศุกร์ที่
25 ค่ะเดือนเดือนกุมภาพันธ์
ปีพตตปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีค.ศต.ค.ปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอาทิตย์
วันอาทิตย์ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันอาทิตย์ที่ 27
กะเดือนเดือนกุมภาพันธ์
ปีพตตปีพต 2  5  6 ห้าปีค.ศขอปีคศ 2
0225 ค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลาเที่ยง
เที่ยงกี่นาที
36 นาที
12:36 นาทีเป็นเวลากลางวันนะคะเป็นเวลา
กลางวันให้หายไปแล้วอ้าวหรือยังคะผู้หญิง
กินข้าวแล้วค่ะครูฟ้าราคะยังไม่ได้กิน
ข้าวเลยค่ะโอ๊ะหิวบ้างไหมหิวมากหิวมาก
เนาะกินผลไม้ดีไหมคะ
กินผลไม้หรอผู้หญิงอิ่มไม่หิว
แต่ก็โอเคใช่ไหมดีกว่าไม่ได้กินอะไรใช่
แต่ว่าประเทศไทยใช่ไหมประเทศไทยเนี่ยมี
ผลไม้มากๆแล้วก็
365วันหวย 365 วัน
12 เดือนเนี่ยนะคะ
365 วัน 12 เดือน
1 ปี
เหมือนกันใช่มั้ยมีผลไม้มากๆ
โห
วีดีโอที่แล้วสมัยนักเรียนเนี่ยก็รู้แล้ว
ว่าเดือนที่ 1 ถึง
เดือนที่ 1 ถึงเดือนที่ 6 มีผลไม้อะไร
บ้าง
I หานักเรียนแล้วเรียนอยากรู้ไหมว่ามี
ผลไม้อะไรอีกหน่อยแน่นอนค่ะว่าวีดีโอนี้
นะคะเดือนที่ 7 สมัยเดือนที่ 7 เดือนที่ 8
เดือนเต็มที่ 9 เดือนที่สิบเดือนที่ 11
แล้วก็เดือนที่ 12 นก็อปเราก็จะมาบอกนัก
เรียนว่าแต่ละเดือนมีผลไม้อะไรบ้าง
แล้วบอกมาเช็คครูฟ้าเหมือนเดิมวีดีโอที่
แล้วเนี่ยครูฟ้าเก่งมากดูสิว่าวีดีโอนี้
จะเป็นยังไงนะคะนักแต่เราจะมาเริ่มเดือน
ที่ 7 เนาะตั้งแต่เดือนที่ 7 นะคะโอเคค่ะ
เดือนที่ 7 เดือนอะไรคะครูฟ้าเดือนที่ 7
กรกฎาคมค่ะ
เดือนที่ 8 เดือนอะไรคะ
สิงหาคม
เดือนที่ 9 เดือนอะไรคะกันยายน
4 เดือนที่สิบเดือนอะไรคะ
ตุลาคม
เดือนที่ 11 เดือนอะไรคะ
พฤศจิกายนค่ะเดือนที่สิบสองสิบสองแบบนี้
ไม่รู้เหมือนกันเน๊อะเดือนอะไรคะ
ธันวาคมค่ะแม่สมัยเดือนที่ 7
เดือนที่ 7 กรกฎาคมเดือนที่ 8
สิงหาคมเรียนที่ 9
กันยายนเดือนที่ 10
ตุลาคมเดือนที่ 11
พฤศจิกายนเดือนที่สิบสองพันวาคม
สิบสองเดือนเนาะนิเราก็ไม่ดูในแต่ละเดือน
นะคะว่ามีผลไม้อะไรบ้างน้องอ่ะอ่ะเรา
เริ่มตั้งนักเรียนที่ 7 ซึ่งก็คือเดือน
กรกฎาคม 5 เดือน
กรกฎาคมผลไม้ที่มีมากๆก็คือ
น้อยหน่า
น้อยหน่าอะไรนักเรียนนักเรียนเห็นผลไม้
แบบนี้มันชื่อน้อยหน่านะคะแล้วก็
ลำไย
น้อยหน่าลำไยเดือนกรกฎาคม
ต่ออะไรเดือนที่ 8 เดือนอะไรนะคะมันไม่
ต้องมานี้นักเรียนที่ 8 เดือนที่ 8
สิงหาคมค่ะเดือนสิงหาคมก็จะมี
ฝรั่งนะคะฝรั่งฝรั่งแล้วก็สับปะรด 6
สับปะรดกลับมานะฝรั่งจับสับปะรด
ฝรั่งรถกะนักเรียนที่ 9 เดือนอะไรนะคะฟ้า
เรียนที่ 9 กันยายนเดือนกันยายนนะครับ
ผลไม้ที่มีมากๆก็คือมาเฟือง
เมาส์เอี่ยมนักเรียนช่วยเห็นมั้ย
เฟืองแล้วก็
มะยมมะเฟืองและมะยมค่ะมั้ยมเนี่ย
นะฮะๆเนาะมาเฟืองกับมะยมณเดือนกันยายน
เนาะอย่ายนต์เดือนที่สิบเดือนอะไรนะคะครู
ฟ้า
ตุลาคมค่ะเดือนตุลาคมนะครับผลไม้ที่มีมาก
ๆก็คือแก้วมังกรโหแก้วมังกรนักเรียนน่าจะ
ชอบก็
ล้างสารนะคะจริงๆมันคล้ายๆกันแล้วนะ
ปราสาทนางนะมีลางสาด
เดือนที่ 11 เดือนอะไรนะคะครูฟ้า
พฤศจิกายนค่ะ
พฤศจิกายนนะผลไม้ที่มีมากๆก็คือส้มส้ม
แล้วก็
ละมุดละมุดละมุดในรู้จักมั้ยบุรี
ละมุดแล้วก็ส้มนะคะมีมากๆเดือน
พฤศจิกายนแล้วก็บินสุดท้ายเดือนที่ 12
เดือนอะไรคะ
ธันวาคมค่ะเดือน
ธันวาคมนะผลไม้ที่มีมากๆก็คือกล้วยหอม
กล้วยหอมว่าของแล้วก็
Strawberry  Strawberry
อาหาร Miss  berry  kit ไทยนะต่อเบอร์รี่
ไทยนะคะ
ก็เดือนที่ 22 สมัยอ่ะเรามาฟังอีกหนึ่ง
ครั้งนะคะครูฟ้าเนี่ยจะพูดเดือน
เบียนรถยี่เดือนที่ 7
กรกฎาคมกรกฎาคมและมีลำไย
น้อยหน่าอ่ะเดือนที่ 8
สิงหาคมเดือนสิงหาคมมีสับปะรด
ฝรั่งนะคะเดือน
กันยายนเดือนกันยายนมีมะยม
มะเฟือง
[เพลง]
ตุลาคมเดือนตุลาคมมีลางสาด
แก้วมังกร
อ่าอันนี้เนื้อ
พฤศจิกายน
พฤศจิกายนมีละมุดนะคะมีละมุดแล้วก็ส้ม
โอเคเดี๋ยวเดือน 12 เดือน 12
เดือนธันวาคม
กันว่าเป็นธันวาคมเนี่ยมีกล้วยหอมแล้วก็
สตรอเบอรี่
เดี๋ยวครูหญิงเนี่ยจะเอาผลไม้ทั้งหมด
เนี่ยนะคะผสมพระผสมผสมกันน้องไม่ๆไม่
เรียนตาม 7  8  9 นะคะแล้วก็จะหยิบ 1 ใบ
แล้วก็ถามครูฟ้าว่ามีมากๆเดือนอะไรเลยเลย
ครูฟ้าจะจำได้ไหมนะคะเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงขอหน้า
กระดานมาเขียนเดือนก่อนเนาะได้หักเรียน
ที่ 7 เดือนอะไรนะคะคือฟ้าเดือนเดือนที่ 7
เดือน
กรกฎาคมเปลี่ยน 17 มหาเดือนกรกฎา
สกรูนะคะนักเรียนครู 2 คนก็คือเมานะคะ
เรียนที่ 8 เดือนอะไรนะคะเดือนที่ 8
สิงหาคมค่ะเดือนที่ 9 เดือนอะไรคะ
กันยายนเดือนที่สิบเดือนอะไรคะ
ตุลาคมเดือนที่ 11 เดือนอะไรคะ
พฤศจิกายนแล้วก็เดือนที่ 12 เดือนอะไรคะ
ธันวาคม
ไอ้ติ๊กหนิกให้ครูฝาพูดเดือนแล้วฟ้าก็ลืม
มันก็จะมาเอาไม่
โอเคครูหญิงจะหยิบดีขึ้นมาแล้วนะคะครูฟ้า
สับปะรด
สับปะรดเนี่ยมีมากๆ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนสิงหาคม 5 กูว่าคุณไม่
ต้องคิดเลยหรอ
สิงหาคมรถฟ้าหรอกว่าสับปะรดสับปะรดเนี่ย
มีมากๆเดือน
สิงหาคม
รัก
สีฟ้าคุณซิกแซ็กจดไว้หรือเปล่าฮ่าๆไม่มี
ค่ะไม่มีทาง
ถ้ากูฟ้าเขียนเอาไว้ใช่ไหมจดเอาไว้นัก
เรียนนักเรียนก็จะเห็นเนอะอ่ะต่อไปค่ะครู
ฟ้า
อะไรลางสาดนะหลานสาดน้องมาแล้วเห็นไหม
ลังสาดนะคะร้านสาดเนี่ยมีมากๆเดือนมีอะไร
ตุลาคมค่ะเดือนตกราคม
ของใหม่สั่งได้วะ
[เพลง]
มีอะไรอ่ะต่อไปห่า
อ่าอันนี้ละกันฝรั่งนะครับฝรั่งมีที่มากๆ
เดือนอะไร
ฝรั่งมีมากๆเดือน
สิงหาคมหักเดือน
สิงหาคม
ถูกต้องเยอะ
ดีมากๆเดือน
สิงหาคม
สาธุ
น่ากลัวมากต่อไปค่ะมาเฟืองนะคะอ่าอา
มาเฟืองมีมากๆ
เดือนอะไรคะครูฟ้าเดือนกันยายนค่ะเดือน
กันยายนครูเค้าบอกเดือนกันยายนค่ะ
กันยายน
ม็อบเฟืองสวยดีมากๆเดือนกันยายนกันยายน
ต่อไปค่ะครูฟ้า
น้อยหน่านะน้อยน้อยหน่ามีมากๆเดือนอะไร
กรกฎาคม
หักเดือน
กรกฎาคมถูกต้องค่ะ
น้อยหน้ามีมากๆเดือน
กรกฎาคม
ส้ม
ส้มครูฟ้าชอบนะส้มเนี่ยร่วงมากค่ะคุณครู
ฟ้าโชว์ส้มมากๆถ้าพูดฟ้าอาทิตย์
ไม่เค็มไม่โอเคอ่ะส้มนะคะส้มมีมากๆเดือน
อะไร
พฤศจิกายนค่ะอยากรู้ป๊าบอกว่า
พฤศจิกายน
ต้นตาที่มีแบบ
โจ๊กภูฟ้ารู้น้ำส้มมีมากๆเดือน
พฤศจิกายนนะคะค่ะต่อไปค่ะ
ละมุดเนาะละมุด
ละมุดมีมากๆเดือนอะไร
พฤศจิกายนค่ะเอาเหมือนกันหรอเหมือนกัน
เนี่ยรู้สึกสิกายนต์
เย้
แล้วมุดมีมากๆนี้นะคะเดือน
พฤศจิกายนแบบต่อไปค่ะครูฟ้า
แก้วมังกร
แก้วมังกรมีมากๆเดือนอะไร
ตุลาคม
เดือน
ถูกค่ะคือผู้หญิง
ที่ไหนข้างค่ะหรอกูยังอยู่ไหมคะคุยกัน
อยู่ค่ะฮัลโหล
กลับมาค่ะนักเรียนผู้หญิงกลับมาแล้วนะคะ
ก็อย่างนี้แหละผู้หญิงถามว่าแก้วมังกรมี
มาม่าสมัยกูฟ้าบอกว่าเดือนตุลาคมใช่ไหมคะ
ถูกต้องค่ะไก่ค่ะคุณก็จะบอกว่า
เนาะมังกร
ถ้าท่านมีมากๆเดือน
ตุลาคม
ต่อไปค่ะ
มะยมนะคะไม่ยมมีมากๆเดือนอะไร
กันยายนค่ะครูฟ้าบอกว่าเดือนกันยายนยา
ยนต์
หน้าสิกุ๊กต้องครั้ง
ประยงค์มะยมเป็นมีมากๆเดือน
กันยายนนะคะ
Strawberry  Strawberry มีมากๆเดือนอะไร
ธันวาคมค่ะลูกค้าบอกเดือน
ธันวาคม
[เพลง]
สตรอเบอรี่มีมากๆเดือน
อารมณ์อ่ะลำไยค่ะ
ลำไยมีมากๆเดือนอะไร
กรกฎาคมเมือง
กรกฎาคมถูกต้องค่ะเราเรียนมาเดือน
กรกฎาคม
วางผิดซะงั้นสุดท้ายค่ะกล้วยหอมกล้วยหอม
มีมากๆๆเดือนอะไร
ธันวาคมค่ะน้ำธันวาคมถูกต้องค่ะ
กล้วยหอมมีมากๆเดือน
ธันวาคมเนาะ
นักเรียนรถเบอร์ให้ครูฟ้าอ่ะ
โอ๊ยลูกช้างเก่งมาก
วีดีโอนี้ครูฟ้าถูก
100%
ว่า
นะเก่งมากนะคะฟังกันอีก 1 รอบนะคะว่าตั้ง
แต่เดือนที่ 7 ใช่ไหมจนถึงเดือน 12
ผลไม้อะไรบ้างสาขาได้ค่ะผู้หญิงเดือนที่ 7
เดือนกรกฎาคมหาก็จะมีลำไย
น้อยหน่า
เดือนที่ 8 สิงหาคม
ฝรั่ง
สับปะรด
คือเรียนที่ 9 กันยายน
มาเฟือง
มะยม
เดือนที่ 10 ตุลาคม
แก้วมังกร
และ
ล้างสาร
เดือนที่ 11
พฤศจิกายน
ละมุด
ส้ม
เดือนที่ 12
อะไรเนี่ยสิบสองพันวาคม
รวยหอม
สตรอเบอรี่นะคะพี่ก็คือผลไม้ในแต่ละเดือน
ใช่ไหมคะที่แล้วก็ครูฟ้าเก่งมากเพราะ
เกลืออีกหนึ่งครั้งนะคะเก่งมากนะคะส่วน
วันนี้วีดีโอนี้เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนเนาะแล้ว
เจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะบ๊ายบายสวัสดี
ค่ะอ่ะ